bonjour madame ça va il a bien dormi
jours un premier volet et le soleil est
là car je lai de vendée moi c'est jean
marie et je suis un des aides soignants
qui s'occupera de toi le matin il est
d'accord oui il est d'accord sur
propices et idéales avec d'autres hommes
tu te rends pas bien compte les
toilettes c'est une espèce de rêve pour
moi d'avoir tétraplégique incomplet
coule un peu plus la plage juste quoi
c'est christiane simon et soignante à
mesure un téléphone avec des sexes comme
ça franchement françois on est obligé la
halle et des fois tu me maltraites je
suis pas un bon patient c'est ça si tu
fais ça parce que je suis moi pas du
tout respire c'est bon comme ça tu es
bien
open
yes
[Musique]
je peux passer le sel un bond de thé
travail qui se compose comme temps rien
branler ici règle numéro un patient son
pote
faut que tu commences à penser comme un
handicap est un faux sur les d'espoir
[Musique]
parce qu'avoir des regrets
si tu as envie
si dell comment j'ai pas de moteur ben
faleh tetra faut pas faire les choses à
moitié et voulait nous handicaper vous
respectez pas les anciens
cette optique toi
[Musique]
le témoin qui regrette que mes photos
sait jamais ce faisant un gros cul
[Musique]